first of all you close the show with a
bang
I closed with a bang you closed with a
bang the three rules the three rules
respect that last one though yeah
where'd you come up with that one from
uh Where'd I come up with the yeah that
last rule
I always you know just playing playing
what was a good way to get off the stage
I mean you gotta remember at the root
some comic so I could write a joke yeah
so I wrote it again
no it was a good one too by the way
or what does it mean to receive this
award tonight and is I mean because
you're not career's not over so what
does it mean to receive this award well
actually my career is over
did you end it no no it's uh this is
nice it's nice to to get to get some
recognition and and get a nice award you
and you appreciate it more when you're
older yeah yeah and it means more to you
yeah what's what's she where's Michelle
going she's standing here she's supposed
to be standing right here
she doesn't want to come she wasn't
supposed to be standing here next year
kicking it we're doing both but no
really what does this word mean to you
what does it mean it's a it's a
prestigious award and uh like I said
what to receive stuff like this when
you're older you really appreciate it
more yeah you do listen you just sat up
there and said 46 years in the business
41 years doing movies and your career
was a success because you kept Will
Smith's wife name out your mouth yeah
no I said that's the that's the
blueprint the blueprint
yeah because in reality I've worked with
Jada
oh don't say your name I love will I
love will and I love I love Chris and
will and it's all love
we can have one of those beer Summits
like Obama did you know when he was
healing stuff you could do that this
year maybe try to get them back together
dirty work they'll work it out okay so I
was interviewing Jerry Bruckheimer on
the carpet and he said you're done with
Beverly Hills Cop you're done filming
oh yeah okay so take us back what
happened I thought that he told you I
was done like I'm never doing anything
because when we stopped making the movie
I was like
I'm not doing no more Beverly Hills Cop
because it was so so hard
so I did better because I did Beverly
Hills Cop when I was 21. I'm 61. so go
play any character you played when he
was 21 and it just was and it's a
physical action movie and you know it
was just really really hard and they
would have to there was one time when I
was supposed to be running down some
steps and uh the director after the tech
came and said uh can we get another one
with with the greatest faster and the
greatest sense of urgency and I was like
I was maxed out that's maxed out
but Jerry said that this one's emotional
Eddie that we're seeing your heart in
this one yeah because it has to do with
you and your daughter now tell me about
it well it's emotional because like I
said I was 61 and I was doing action
scenes and you see my heart beating
through my chest because I had many
times where I felt like I was going to
die on this set it's just you know I
know some actors get into doing that
type of
stunts and stuff and before the movie I
said to Jerry and I said listen
61. don't ask me to do that you wouldn't
ask Morgan Freeman to do
they said oh no we're going to have
somebody have the dude coming to stunt
double and I said okay but then it was
there's some stuff that you have to do
so I find myself jumping and running and
rolling around and it was a lot
you also have your new movie with Nia
and Jonah you people yes which I'm so
excited for people to see is so funny
and edgy and smart and Kenya bearish
directed it and wrote it with Jonah and
uh
you know most romantic comedies are just
uh funny and sweet and uh this is kind
of like the way uh
Guess Who's Coming to Dinner had this
Edge to it because it's just this this
race conversation and it gave it this
Edge that it's not usually in romantic
comedies okay
Jamie Lee Curtis comes up to help
present the Cecil B Demille award to you
you guys were in trading places together
in 83. she's in the new Honda 40 years
ago 40 years ago 40 years ago
she's in what she's in the new Haunted
Mansion
the new Haunted Mansion they'd made a
new Haunted Mansion movement yes
will you be in the new Haunted Mansion
well I did a Haunted Mansion movie and
it didn't it wasn't very good so I don't
know if they want to bring the old
baggage and have me stinking up the new
one
My Haunted Mansion was not all that
would you stop Eddie every movie my no
My Haunted Mansion was not all that in
the bag of chips
what would you call it and by the way
Tracy was pretty funny tonight always
funny I love Tracy Martin yeah I love
him and he talked about what Delirious
meant to him and also we got a chance to
see that retrospective what went through
your mind is you watched all those
things that you've done throughout your
career
I don't know if anything was you know
what was going through my mind right
before that it was so cold
where we were sitting that I literally
had to get up and go in the back and
warm up because I started feeling like I
was gonna have a panic attack I was like
shaking so that's what I was thinking
when it was showing that uh video I had
just kind of calmed down it was so I was
and you get nervous
no it was it was it was so cold and it
was already had a little nervous energy
and I have anxiety so it kind of sitting
there for like three hours I don't know
if we would like right under it or
whatever but I started getting shaky
yeah
yes I get shaky I'm just I'm just a
human I'm just a human what is the most
what what do people come up to you and
quote the most
say all different kind of you know I
have a lot of catch phrases for movies
it's almost like hooks on records that's
true so people come up and say sexual
chocolate and they say Hercules Hercule
hot tubs
what is that velvet
it's a lot of people come and say
different things yeah but not one more
than the other just no the strangest
thing a person's ever said to me I was
coming out of a hotel once and the guy
said to me uh hey man you still got that
laugh and I said yeah and he said
was that real or was that computers
come on he leaned in
was that computer
did you give him the laugh that no I
just kind of how do you what do you do
when someone says I just kind of looked
then I left I walked away were you kids
watching tonight
uh I hope so come on they're not well
you got a couple young my little ones
they were they were all sitting and
watching uh but it's past their bedtime
so
yeah they might have caught the tail end
of it uh and my big ones they're all
over the place the big ones that are
here I'm sure they're here with you some
are here to know the big ones that are
in the states yeah okay but a couple of
my daughters are
traveling you have it like and you like
have you gotten over your daughter
getting married you're walking her down
the aisle you're giving her away well
that was just a beautiful thing yeah
except I caught covid
who else no no a bunch of people caught
covet and we had testing and all that
and then we found out afterwards that
people were going past the testing you
know I tested already we didn't have any
security out there we just thought
everybody would take their test with
people kind of like bum rush the wedding
and then came and hugged you then aft
then right after the wedding we fly out
too uh uh to my we meet my daughter on
our honeymoon in Hawaii wait you on your
daughter's honeymoon no no she went to
first she went the first week
by herself
in the second week you showed up then
the second week we flew out and the
moment I landed I tested positive for
covet and had to stay in the hotel room
isolate the whole vacation but just you
know another one in my door two of my
daughters quoted in me but I I was the
one paying for everything because I had
to be on the balcony looking down at
everybody having fun and eating and
waving they had a great time yeah so I'm
gonna take another Pax loving
see y'all in about six days
end up right before the pandemic hit and
uh I was thinking getting ready to go to
the clubs and start working out then
that hole started and I and I was nuts
about covet I stayed in my house for two
years
but literally literally two years I was
like didn't leave the ground and go
outside and uh then when it all calmed
down I started making movies again and
it's now it's like oh you're going to go
do stand-up and it's like yeah I guess
so that's still the plan to do stand-ups
but now I got to do two or three movies
now
you were so cautious and after you
turned around and got called Kobe as
soon as you went out in the world after
do George Clinton first before I do
before I do stand-up
[Music]